Apple's iPhone 12 event is only three
months away and all of the leaks and
rumors that have been circulating for
the past year are finally starting to
get wrapped up so what I'm going to do
in this video is try to make sense of
all of them in terms of which models we
should expect which features and of
course the release date now before we
begin I want to remind you guys that
Apple doesn't have to go all out to sell
a ton of iPhones they simply need to
change just enough to make the new
iPhones feel different yet up-to-date
with the latest technology and people
will swarm to buy them that's why they
gave the iPhone 11 pro the controversial
triple camera bump some people hated it
but one thing's for sure you can't
mistake it for any other iPhone and
that's what gets people to upgrade so
this year with the iPhone 12 lineup
Apple simply has to change the design
enough to make it instantly stand out
and the way they're going to achieve
that is by flattening the edges similar
to the iPhone 5 design but I myself
personally think that it'll be a more
subtle change so not quite as boxy as
the iPad pro and that's it that's the
only exterior change that they need to
make this year so they can keep the same
camera bumps as the iPhone 11 lineup and
they can keep the same old lightning
port and they'll still sell a ton of
phones because if you see an iPhone with
flat edges and a notch you'll know that
it's an iPhone 12 but of course they're
still gonna have to make some internal
changes and I'll get into that in just a
minute but for now I want to get into
the lineup that we should expect and
explain why it's such a genius idea a
lot of people were surprised to see that
the iPhone 11 was 50 dollars cheaper
than the iPhones and are and it didn't
really make sense until now the base
model iPhone 12 is actually rumored to
start at an even cheaper 650 dollars and
you might ask how the heck can they get
the price so low and why the reason for
that is because the new iPhone 12 is
gonna have a smaller 5.4 inch display
which makes it cheaper to produce and
they'll actually offer a plus sized
iPhone 12 model which
be identical in specs but have a 6.1
inch display for 750 dollars which is
ironically the same exact size and price
as the iPhones had are at launch this is
a genius move because those who don't
want a small 5.4 inch display have the
option of paying $100 more for the max
model instead of having to go from one
of the more expensive pro models and
speaking of those the iPhone 12 pro is
rumored to also get a 6.1 inch display
and the pro max model will get a 6 point
7 inch display this actually makes the
most sense because Apple will only have
three display sizes for a total of four
iPhone models making it cheaper to
manufacture compared to having four
different sizes now for that base five
point four inch model it could actually
share the same exact body as the iPhone
se except without the home button and
with a notch bringing that 4.7 inch
display size up to five point four
inches so there are even less
manufacturing costs for Apple leading to
the new low price of only six hundred
and fifty dollars now I don't know if
you guys remember all of those leaks
about the iPhone se coming with face ID
a notch and an OLED display well it
seems like those leaks were actually the
5.4 inch iPhone 12 so this points to
every iPhone in the 20/20 lineup finally
getting in oled display and just like
before we can expect every single iphone
this year to come with the new 5
nanometer a 14 Bionic chip which will be
incredibly powerful we can also expect
the entire lineup to start with 128
gigabytes of base storage and this would
make sense because it's easier and
cheaper to mass-produce that based
storage size for the entire lineup just
like they've already done for the iPad
pro lots of rumors are also pointing to
the iPhone 12 no longer coming with ear
pods in the box and in my opinion this
is honestly a good move since I
personally had about 4 or 5 sets of
these ear pods until I finally gave them
away so this is a clever move by Apple
to sell more ear pods
and this would make sense since there's
a chance that Apple will introduce a new
ear pods model alongside the iPhone 12
at the September event we should also
expect to get the same 5 watt charger in
the box with the base models unlike the
new 18 watt fast charger that comes with
the iPhone 11 Pro and before we move on
to specifically talking about the pro
models I want to mention that we should
expect the same exact 4 gigs of ram on
the lower end iphone 12 and 12 macs as
well as the same dual cameras as the
iphone 11 don't expect any other major
changes like smaller bezels or a smaller
notch because remember apple is already
giving it a new square at design and 128
gigs of storage at a great price there's
no reason for them to drastically change
anything else on the exterior and don't
forget there's also going to be some new
software features as well to help
sweeten the deal now before we get into
the iPhone 12 pro models I want to
mention that we finally got our all over
premium Apple product pattern t-shirt
updated for 2020 with subtle icons like
ear pods pro the new Mac Pro the pro
display XDR and even the new iPad pro
with the square camera bump so if you
guys want to help support us you can buy
a t-shirt right below this video in our
teespring word shelf now on to the pro
models we should expect a brand new
midnight blue color now you may have
seen the rumor that we won't get an L
TPO display on an iPhone until 2021
which possibly means that we won't get a
high refresh rate 120 Hertz display but
keep in mind that Apple doesn't
necessarily need that tech to get a high
refresh rate display since the 10.5 inch
iPad pro was the first Apple device to
get a 120 Hertz display back in 2017 if
Apple doesn't add a 120 Hertz display on
the iPhone 12 Pro this year they're in
trouble because basically every other
Android phone already has a high refresh
rate display and the reason for LTP o
next year would be to help save battery
life and maybe even add an always-on
display feature rumors are also pointing
to a new display with 10-bit color depth
but I don't expect it to get much
brighter
the iPhone 11 pro is already incredibly
bright the iPhone 12 pro max model is
rumored to get a larger 6.7 inch display
possibly with slimmer bezels in a
smaller notch but they'll most likely
have to make the phone itself a little
bit larger to fit that display it will
most likely also come with 5g which I
personally don't care about at all since
4G is fast enough on my iPhone 11 pro
but for the new iPhone 12 lineup the
millimeter wave 5g tech will probably
only come on the pro models in the
cheaper iPhone 12 models might simply
get the sub 6 5g which is more like
faster 4G instead of real 5g
there's a chance that the pro models
will also come with the same lidar
scanner that came on the 20/20 iPad pro
now you might be asking what's the point
of that scanner well it seems as though
Apple will have some surprises for us in
terms of this new sensor at their WWDC
event on June 22nd and once again we
should expect to see the same lightning
port as before so no USB C port this
year and finally more rumors are
pointing to the pro models getting
bumped up to 6 gigabytes of RAM
alongside the new 128 gigabyte based
storage at the same prices as last year
$1000 for the pro and $1,100 for the pro
max now in terms of when we should
expect the release date some new rumours
are showing that these iPhones will be
getting delayed pointing to a quarter
for release date but don't freak out
quarter 4 actually starts in October
just three weeks after the usual
September event date so if we do get
delays it'll most likely be like the
iPhone 10 R which came out on October
26th and it absolutely shouldn't be any
worse than the iPhone 10 which came out
on November 3rd and as far as the date
of the iPhone event itself that
absolutely won't get delayed and it's
always been on either a Tuesday or a
Wednesday so September the 9th makes the
most sense and more than likely it'll be
an online-only event just like the
upcoming WWDC event on June 22nd in
which that will act as a test
run for the online-only September event
so hopefully you guys enjoy this video
and let me know down in the comments
below if you agree with my thoughts on
the new features of the iPhone 12 and
make sure to check out this brand new
t-shirt in our merch shelf right below
this video thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next one
[Music]